but uh let's jump into that uh that
first story nbc news reports
12 national guard members removed from
inauguration duty
including two for inappropriate comments
the fbi has been screening all service
members involved with the inauguration
amid growing security concerns they say
quote
we have two individuals that were
identified as making inappropriate
comments or
texts i got to stop and just ask what is
it what does that mean did they did they
make they post a meme of hillary clinton
or something and all sudden they're
getting
kicked out well it's also stuff that
they retweeted that supposedly is
is is bad content but we're again
getting very generalized language
no exact examples and we should at least
get that with the latest news and again
it's 12 out of 25
000. it's not a whole lot but it is kind
of weird they're doing it yeah i got to
be honest
so actually i have a twitter thread from
jack posobik he says
white house source the nra turning point
usa
and patriot guard writers are three of
many non-militia groups on the list
cid and fbi are using the
cross-reference in vetting for potential
extremists
why yeah what is that young americans
for freedom yep also on the list quote
they're looking at various tp turning
point usa chapters
in almost every university and high
school where there is one for example
high school members who are in the
future soldiers program
which is army's version of delayed entry
program college age soldiers obviously
already in
investigators also looking for the
following in pictures
maga cag apparel gadsden flag
confederate flag nra gear and q stuff i
can understand some of that but the
gadsden flag
i mean at any rate it's all free speech
soldiers
facebooks twitters ins uh twitter
instagram tick tocks and snapchats are
also being checked
units from deep red states such as texas
being thoroughly examined
left-wing anarchist groups also listed
but not a top priority
in fact zero have been investigated as
of this evening leaders in both the army
and the fbi
have directed to focus attention on
groups with strong conservative
sentiments
ncis afosi cgis
also expected to receive that directive
from senior dod officials
in the coming days this goes way beyond
the inauguration
it won't magically stop after tomorrow
so this
is actually kind of freaky seeing this
because you've got democrats concerned
that someone what has a gadsden flag
and so they're going to investigate
people and remove them from their
mission if that's the case
are we really at the point where you
know we had we had chris cuomo on cnn
say we can't trust our military i mean
i see stuff like that and i think of two
words
you know what those two words are guys
hmm luke's got a smile on his face
i was going to say fish sticks i don't
want to get i don't want to get the
iranians a civil war
civil war you know i don't i don't like
those words
but uh i've been talking about it uh for
some time
and it started when as i mentioned
always i was reading and i think it was
like new york mag or the atlantic
they did uh so so uh for you steve i'll
give you the context there was an
article where they interviewed a bunch
of national security experts
from various major security companies
and asked them what
what percentage likelihood they thought
it you know we were
we had for a potential civil war and
they said in the next 10 years like the
average i think was like 35
or or higher some people said 95 percent
chance and then watching the escalation
of the culture war and
the escalation of politics to this point
where we had a bunch of trump supporters
you know stormed through the front doors
of the capitol building
i mean there have been people every step
of the way we've seen some some kind of
escalation they've said no
no no no of course not well now we had a
retired army general i believe army
saying that we've not had this much
security at an inauguration since
abraham lincoln
so it really does feel like we are
knocking on the door for some kind of
major catastrophe now that being said
it doesn't mean it's true everything
could stop right now tomorrow could go
off without a hitch and then everyone
has to slow down and calm down
i just don't see anything happening betw
with the rhetoric from politicians from
high profile personalities
that would indicate things are going to
calm down i mean you got aoc you've got
these leftist corey bush saying expel
the insurrectionist republicans
and so it feels like it's we're boiling
over and we're getting that point
now there's two before i i want to ask
you this steve
your business thrives when there's when
there's chaos and i mean with all due
respect like when when the news is bad
people are going to start thinking about
what they have to do to survive
so you know with that in mind i imagine
you've been tracking a lot of this stuff
you're paying attention to politics to
know what might happen what people might
do and i'd be interested to get your
thoughts on on all of this and what you
think it means
well partly what we're seeing
happening with so much of the
military presence is because it's so
fresh so
there's always an overreaction
especially when you look in the
political arena because everybody one
has to
cover themselves politically and then
you know two this really hasn't happened
before
and it's shocking it's like
a 9 11 type shock to the country
but it hit so close to home to those
inside those chambers
that's why you're seeing what you're
seeing now will it go away
quickly i would imagine it'll stay for a
little while
things will have to calm down because
like you said the rhetoric
it's not going to stop now it becomes
what will will it become a payback
scenario for
how the impression is of what was done
to donald trump
so are we now going to try to do that to
joe biden
i think yes we've had i think was
marjorie taylor green
said she's gonna file for impeachment
day one day one so so here we go
i mean is is it possible we hit that
ceiling where this is the level of
tension we get
and then we never cross into that
territory of actual disruption of supply
lines and fighting
it's possible but what's going to happen
now groups are going to start to try to
vie for attention so there was uh there
was a
highway that was stopped by a black
lives matter group
which we haven't seen in a little bit
right that seemed to has calmed down but
everybody now is
going to vie for the attention of the
incoming
uh administration and so the
administration comes in with like a
like a debit card of capital
influence and depending on how it's
spent it either
will grow or it will dissipate and so
everybody wants to make sure the
attention's on
them so they can get a piece of all that
and an important aspect to really
remember here a lot of the left has been
incentivized by making a lot of noise
making a lot of trouble
creating a lot of violence and then
being heard so there's also an
examples of them literally looting
rioting and then getting their way
so that's another thing to consider
moving forward in this larger kind of
political spectrum getting defended by
kamala harris and joe biden's
administration
so you know you know what's interesting
is we didn't get this reaction when we
had black lives matter riots
sweeping across the country i mean did
you you guys didn't activate the ranches
when all those riots were happening
no no but the election you did we did so
the way we cover our members is there's
a anxiety clause
so if something happens locally if we're
not
completely activated officially they can
come
you know they're a member they they can
come if something happens
locally because there's no way to
predict how these things are going to go
so so if let's say like so you're west
virginia if somebody lives in safe
pennsylvania and there's a major
disaster in their town
yes they can come to the ranch
absolutely because it's about you know
their survival they can't just go
anywhere i'd love somewhere to go
right right on so i guess you know when
we're looking at what's going on in dc
and
everything's happened over the past 10
years the escalation i mentioned that
article where they
talk about security experts giving their
predictions do you think
that we are on track for some kind of
political instability i
i'm not going to say you know a civil
war but instability to the point where
you will have your members coming in for
safety and security
well it's so so it depends things are
so fresh things are very raw
we so we rate these things we give out
certain
um levels for
when we put out our newsletters to our
members so that they understand what the
different factors are
you know whether it be from uh something
happening with nuclear to
to a war all of the different factors
that you have to worry about
and we have at a five percent right now
as far as
um what is the danger for civil unrest
and five percent in the sense of how it
would affect
uh we're always looking towards the
collapse scenario
yeah however you get there probably
through a few crises right
yeah yeah yeah so you know just like
kovid kogita was a wake-up call because
we were completely unprepared
again that was a 9 11 event something
you don't prepare for you don't see
coming
and boom there it is but you know we've
been talking about it for a while
and the fact is we're
we're talking about 1.8 mobility
more mortality yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the nerve agent so then
um what happens if that was five percent
we'd already this would be a completely
different climate
and that's not even talking ab bio
engineered
type of viruses it's doable
we don't believe that that's what
happened with with kovid but it is
doable that technology
exists and that should be enough to
scare anyone you know again
we're not doomsday you know
type prepper people we believe the
world's ending tomorrow
and all this type of thing but the fact
that that is out there
and can be released really should be an
eye opener
i'll just mention too you mentioned the
nerve agent for those that uh
before the show you mentioned that what
you're uh you were in i think
iraq and you got swept over by sarin
yeah well yeah it was during desert
storm when we finally wound up there so
that i just want to give quick context
i definitely want to get into that stuff
later but people are probably wondering
what you meant when you pointed your
head and said nerve agent yeah if i
if i get blocked and thought it's it's
just the synapsis is trying to reconnect
up there
well specifically what you were talking
about before was gain of
function studies that have proven to
have no scientific basis at all but is
pretty much when scientists come
together
and they're literally trying to create
the worst destructive disease or virus
possible
and a lot of times this is funded by a
lot of
taxpayer-funded money and everyone's
scratching their head like why is this
going on dr
fauci was a part of financing this also
in uhan
and just the fact that they continue
this type of research is something to of
course worry about which is why i think
you're putting it in your
right assessment weaponization yeah i
think i think i think it's simple you
say there's no scientific benefit of
course they
it's it's the new frontier of war right
it's horrifying
what they did i mean you look at the i
mean mustard gas you look at sarin gas
you look at what these things do to
people
agent orange yeah nightmare nightmarish
horrifying well the next level up is a
self-replicating contagion
imagine if you could make sarin gas but
would replicate itself and spread to
other people
well that's that's part of this research
i can only imagine
that the military's got some crazy stuff
did you prep the story about the
scientists who said he
hadn't well it's from the daily caller
the title is u.s scientist who led
charge against covet lab
uh leak theory admits he was trying to
protect chinese scientists so this guy
came out and said it did not leak from
the chinese lab
and he now he admits that he was trying
to protect the chinese scientists
so we we don't have any confirmation of
the lab leak theory but i will say it's
strange that new york i think it was new
york magazine it's always i think new
york magazine
they uh they wrote an article going
through the theory that
it was i guess the idea is they were
trying to do research on it
either to make a vaccine and i'm not
saying it's true youtube calm down
this is what was published in a
prominent new york publication where a
guy wrote
that there is a very real theory among
scientists that it was an accidental
release
that they were at they were engineering
this for a variety of reasons and made a
mistake yeah
there's also some video footage going
around showing how
one of the scientists at this level
three wuhan lab was actually bitten by a
bat
and had had covid like symptoms all the
way back a few years ago but there's
as you were saying it's almost
impossible to prove
that it did come out of that lab
especially with china
locking out the world health
organization for over a year
from even investigating the origins of
the sickness but but kind of continuing
back on the military aspect since you
were in the military
i really specifically was was dying to
ask you what do you think it does to
morale to be vetted like we're seeing
the vetted going on right now and how is
the political kind of climate
affecting the military and and how do
you think it would be affected from your
experience in the middle east you know
it's a
interesting question because certainly
during my time and never experienced
anything like that we never had
such heightened political tension that
it was really a factor when you
you sat around in the barracks or
something it really wasn't
you know part of my experience but i
i can tell you from anybody who is
serving who has served
it's like a slap in the face
it's something you take pride in i mean
i think it's one percent of all of all
of the 330 some odd million people
only one percent serve yeah and i have
to imagine
of these 12 guards that got removed they
probably have a lot of friends
who are still there on the mission and i
can only imagine
they're not happy about being being
removed i'm sure they kind of just say
like yeah you know that's that's the
game you get orders
you follow your orders well they'll do
their duty right that when it comes down
to it
they'll do their duty but but like you
mentioned a slap in the face
i have to imagine their friends probably
feel you know loyal to their friends you
know
someone you serve with someone you know
when you trust and then they say no this
person's not trustworthy get them out of
here
and you're like dude come on like what's
what's the what's the what's the deal
yeah well you're deemed as a threat for
liking something online or retweeting
something
now we don't know what we're getting the
symbol of the american revolution a
symbol of the american revolution
is grounds for removing you from your
duty to protect the capital to the nra
people that have so that's yeah part
part of jackpot's threat is they're
saying that some people who like posted
or associated with the nra
it's all it's insane that's right kind
of mixed feelings like
you need to protect your military and if
you have traders in the military that's
a problem but
assuming these people are traders is
also can be a problem and that's a
that's a dark road
that's i mean that's a big word traitor
the pro the problem is
well i think the the legal definition of
trader is actually providing aid or
resource
to an active enemy of the united states
so i think
you know traitor gets thrown around a
whole lot the problem is when it comes
to
people storming into the capitol those
people thought they were the patriots
that by going in there they were
restoring the constitution defending it
and that the people in the chamber they
believed were the bad guys it's
everybody's the hero of their own story
yeah
it's not so simple so so the most
powerful thing in this whole situation
is the media narrative
which is why we're now what two uh uh
just about two weeks
out from the storm of the u.s capital
every day it's been like
50 stories in a variety of ways many of
which are just ridiculous many of which
just
are trying as hard as possible to make
it as crazy as possible
there was one story that came out where
they said it was pre-planned and they
were planning on capturing
taking hostages and assassinating these
people and then like three hours later
that wasn't true we made a mistake so
that's what happens when the media is
driven to pump out the most sensational
insane you know media and i think for a
lot of the people who work for these
news outlets
they're ideologically tribal left
so it fits their narrative and it fits
their bias and they get to write about
this nonstop
and that it's it's everything they
wanted it was it was probably this one
of the stupidest things
anyone could have done is storming into
that capital for a variety of reasons
it's on moral grounds
legal grounds and then an actual
reference to the political landscape
gave the left everything they could have
wanted that there i remember there was i
think
i'm not sure if it was newsweek i think
it was newsweek where they said if trump
loses in twenty
it's like in 2016 said what happens if
trump loses and it's a picture of a
bunch of like
middle-aged white people holding torches
and yelling and screaming
and they're like that's what's going to
happen if trump loses and then trump won
and it was the left that you know kind
of went nuts and we're screaming and the
democrats went after trump trying to
impeach him
well sure enough trump loses this time
and they got their
their prophecy fulfilled by people
storming that capital and they are not
going to let it go they're gonna use it
for all it's worth yeah there there's a
new video going around today that's
called hashtag
trump's new army yeah and uh
it's pretty much calling trump
supporters traitorous terrorists
uh brett weinstein called this out i saw
it from him retweeting it saying this is
essentially trying to get your neighbors
into a civil war
so this is brett weinstein's commentary
on the video that is making its round
around kind of liberal check marks do
you have an opinion about maybe
what happened on the capital or this
kind of political climate that that
seems to be getting
more and more weaponized against each
other
right we we definitely have entered into
a period of lost perspective
no one can understand why the other
person feels that way
and we we need to take a step back
as a country and look at our
you know fellow man differently because
not everyone's the enemy just because
they voted one way
or the other i honestly i don't quite
understand why the line is
drawn so harshly the way
that it's been drawn but this has been
building up for a while
i mean the signs have all been there but
you know when you actually see it uh
erupt like it has
then you know you you really
have to understand that we're still the
same people we were four years ago i
mean
let's let's all calm down for a second i
i think there's a
the ideology is drifting too far too
fast
and uh i think you know people call them
they'll call me a bias but i think the
left is drifting very very for it i
shouldn't
it's not necessarily to the left but the
tribal division is coming from those
associated with
more of the left faction the answer to
groups the example i give is
you know the journalist from cnn i
shouldn't call a journalist the activist
from cnn
who's now calling up cable providers and
telling them to ban
fox news four years ago this guy
interviewed me about defending free
speech
so he's part of this group that has just
drifted further and further into the
extremes i'm sitting in the exact same
place
defending free speech and all that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you